[Music]
it's summer in europe and people are
spending a lot of time outdoors
few are worried about getting kovid now
almost all of the health restrictions
and safeguards have been lifted
but in many places cases are on the rise
again
what stage are we at in the pandemic
that's the question we'll be asking in
this edition of our covid19 special the
head of the world health organization
certainly sounds concerned
with continuing transmission
decreasing testing and sequencing
and 40 percent of the world's population
still unvaccinated
the pandemic is not is not over
it's vital that all countries continue
to vaccinate
especially those most at risk
including health workers and people aged
over 60.
we begin with a look at new coronavirus
studies on long covid and we'll meet a
mexican researcher who's working on a
new treatment for coven 19.
but first to germany
very few restrictions remain here in
everyday life
politicians are debating the possible
introduction of safety measures for the
coming fall in case the country is hit
by another wave of infections
what do people on the street think
we canvassed opinion in berlin
in the evenings when it's cooler and the
sky is still light people spill out onto
berlin's streets and into the parks
on the longest day of the year the fate
de la musique always offers free outdoor
concerts this year the events took place
without any restrictions for the first
time since the start of the pandemic
no proof of vaccination or a negative
covet test was required there wasn't a
mask in sight and no way to socially
distance
many have simply had enough precautions
they want to party together again and
leave the pandemic behind them
it's wonderful it's just real life
though not everyone is so completely
carefree
it does feel a bit strange but it's okay
outside when i go indoors i do wear a
mask
and that's still important on public
transport
but it's nice to be able to be here
outdoors without a mask again
but despite the nice summer weather the
number of coveted cases is rising in
berlin as elsewhere
the seven day incidence now stands at
over 430 per 100 000 people and the
actual number is likely to be far higher
as few people are getting tested now
zabila katzenstein is a gp in berlin
who's been treating covet 19 patients
ever since the pandemic began
in recent weeks she's been seeing more
young people
many find it scary that their
performance is impaired for many weeks
that they feel pressure in their chest
so self-protection is still important
you can't prevent it completely
if you get it you get it
but it's not as if omicron doesn't cause
an unpleasant and often quite protracted
illness
each day between 300 and 500 people come
to this test center in central berlin
its operator says on average 20 percent
of them are testing positive
till now the rapid antigen tests were
performed for free but as of july most
people will have to pay for them
[Music]
in poorer districts it's extremely hard
for people to pay 20 euros or something
for a test
which means that once again
things will split into those who have
money and can get tested
and those in more disadvantaged areas
will be left behind and catch covet more
often
to prepare for the expected rise in
infections the german government plans
to enact new measures before
parliament's summer break
two years ago berlin's first coveted 19
patient was discovered in the mita
district almost by chance ever since the
head of its health authority has fought
for better equipment and more personnel
yet in september the contracts of most
support staff are set to expire
who knows what kind of variant is coming
we'll try once again to reach out to
people who don't have a gp to vaccinate
and advise them
it's high time to start planning things
the current omacron variant has even
caused staff here to take a more relaxed
approach
still dr lucas morita cautions that
anyone who feels ill should stay home
vulnerable groups should get vaccinated
wear masks and enclose spaces that can't
be aired out
otherwise have fun
and having fun is certainly what
berliners are doing
and what does the situation look like in
south africa the highly infectious
omicron variant was discovered here six
months ago
it's now winter and yet the situation
seems very relaxed
[Music]
as south africa is exiting its fifth
coveted wave and restrictions have
largely been lifted normality is
returning to downtown johannesburg
[Music]
yes
that's the one
yeah man the west is past the sun is
shining we're taking some pictures it's
a good day man i'm happy that the coffee
is over now and we
things are coming back to normal
only a few months ago the first global
epicenter of the omicron variant was
right here this area of the steve biko
academic hospital became the immediate
response center for the spike in
hospitalizations at the beginning of the
country's fourth wave late last year
dr farid abdullah runs the hospital's
covert 19 ward
his team published the first paper on
the severity of omicron
[Music]
with omicron in our fourth wave we saw a
decoupling of the cases
and the
debts
and
you know although there were lots of
cases we had fewer hospital admissions
less severity of disease
and and then with our fifth wave with
the ba four and five variants
we had even a continuation of that trend
most of the response wards at the
hospital are being decommissioned
abdullah believes the milder fifth wave
as a result of immunity built from prior
infection or vaccination or both
which provides enough protection against
omicron and other sars cov2 variants
a survey of blood donors has indicated
that about 98 of south africa's
population has likely been exposed to
the virus in some form
though the disease could be becoming
endemic dr abdullah says managing its
spread is still important testing has
completely collapsed
in south africa most people don't test
if they have suspected coven it's only
those people who are severely ill come
to a hospital
who get tested so we can't really
measure our cases by testing
interpreting trends in this new phase
and determining the appropriate public
health response requires alternative
covert 19 indicators
and that's the aim of the south african
medical research council's wastewater
surveillance program
we visit the wastewater plants every
monday we collect up to nine samples and
we use it to detect dead rna in order to
get an idea of the spread of covert 19
in a community
the lab receives the samples analyzes
them and reports results on this
dashboard
these electronic maps depict rna trends
for over 80 sites in some of the
country's most populous districts
at another laboratory genome sequencing
surveillance continues
though immunity to the highly mutated
highly transmissible omicron variant is
likely to grow among the population
scientists advise caution there's always
a possibility for a new variant we don't
always know what drives it but it seems
to be mutations any means decreased
patients also just
herd immunity but it's also possible
that there may be animal reservoirs that
drive additional mutations occurring
researchers agree vaccination is the
best line of defense
vaccination drives like this one aim to
raise awareness and improve take-up
curtailing the spread of the virus is
harder in the cramped living conditions
of many south african townships
it was very hard because we were like so
scared what if somebody get infected so
how are you going to keep the social
distance because now it's a small house
yes
but despite increased access to vaccines
and boosters the country's vaccination
rate stands at just 31
in this community where we work we see
that
people have not been actively taking the
vaccine because first of all
they don't see the numbers as they saw
in the first wave
and they're worried about the side
effects of those
vaccines and they observe those who have
taken them
and the last one is because they don't
trust the government messaging
different contexts affect how covet
develops
while south africa appears to have got
off lightly in the fifth wave the same
might not be the case for other
countries
do you have any questions on covid19
our science correspondent derek williams
has the answers based on the latest
research and analysis
send an email to covetproducer dw.com
this week's question is from ian sush
he asks how soon can we expect vaccines
that target the omicron variant
from the early days of the pandemic
experts have talked a lot about a big
strength of messenger rna vaccines which
is that it's
easy to tweak them to respond to fast
changing pathogens um when the highly
mutated omicron variant hit the scene in
late 2021 it seemed like it was time for
them to really finally start fulfilling
that promise
manufacturers announced that they could
adjust and shift vaccine production
by march
but that promise delivery date passed
months ago and we're still waiting for
omicron specific boosters so what's
taking so long well it's complicated and
the experts that i read say that there
are several issues but
really the central one seems to be that
clinical trials with omicron specific
mrna vaccine so far
have returned kind of a
mixed bag of results omicron specific
vaccines did do better against omicron
than older ones did but not really
significantly better and if they're not
significantly better then it'll be a lot
harder to convince people that they need
an omicron booster
and if people aren't convinced that they
really need them then they just won't
get them which of course
lowers a pharmaceutical company's
incentive to produce them
moderna now wants to provide what's
called a bivalent booster this fall
which is a mix of its old vaccine
against the original virus and a new
omicron specific one pfizer and biontech
also just announced results with an
omicron update vaccine that look
quite positive but
healthcare authorities are still looking
at all that data this issue really boils
down to how
healthcare authorities define the goals
of vaccination
are they to prevent infection completely
but maybe only for a short time
or are they to build up more long-term
protection but only against serious
disease or hospitalization or death
because so far at least existing
vaccines appear to still be doing that
quite well um against omicron too
green lighting an omicron specific
vaccine that just
incrementally improves on that
is not going to be enough to set off new
mass vaccination drives especially
when most experts expect sars kobe 2 to
continue to mutate and
we have no idea what possibly vaccine
resistant variants
might pop up next so
long and short
omicron specific vaccines could be
available by
september or so at least in in bivalent
booster form
but ultimately
now it looks like there'll only be one
piece in the
coronavirus vaccine puzzle
[Music]
to respond to the changing course of the
pandemic researchers worldwide are not
only working on covid vaccines
they're also developing new medications
to help reduce the severity of
infections and minimize the symptoms
the efficacy of these drugs against new
variants needs to be tested continually
we went to mexico to meet a scientist
who's working on a new treatment and has
some hurdles to overcome in the process
[Music]
while many of us were confined to our
homes during the pandemic paula castillo
was also locked up in this laboratory
the microbiologist is developing a
biopharmaceutical that's designed to
stop sars cov2 from entering the cells
and multiplying in the body
it focuses on sequences of the virus
which have so far remained unchanged
meaning it should work for any variant
we're in the process of testing the drug
on all the variants that have emerged so
far
we're expecting it to show 90
effectiveness against all the variants
that would mean that in 90 of cases the
drug prevents sars kov2 from replicating
in human cells
but this still needs to be tested on
animals and later in clinical trials
developing new drugs is a lengthy and
expensive process and one of the biggest
obstacles for paula castillo's work is
finding the funds because mexico's
government has cut the budget for
science and research
when it comes to developing research
projects getting financing in mexico is
difficult
the public funding that we get for our
institute's projects is generally very
limited
young female scientists like castillo
have a particularly hard time in
mexico's male-dominated science
community
the researcher was even urged to abandon
her career after becoming pregnant but
she refused to give up
the biopharmaceutical she's developed
has already passed the first phase and
is due to undergo animal testing soon
but new covet variants are slowing her
down because she has to test her drug
against each one on top of already
dealing with a slashed budget
see you're
if i want to do 50 trials i need to
remember my budget and restrict myself
to what was planned at the start
originally i expected to be done in a
year now we're up to three years because
there's not enough money for what we
need
in two months she hopes to publish
interim results
however one epidemiologist at unam the
largest university in latin america has
expressed doubts about the real
potential of this biopharmaceutical
he points to the lack of reported
evidence and the haste of the
polytechnic institute in publicizing its
findings
only clinical trials which have to be
published can show whether or not a
product is genuinely effective
but here they assume in advance that it
must be effective because they're so
convinced by its molecular structure
but despite the doubts and lack of
funding it could ultimately be the need
for effective ways to combat covet 19
that gives a boost to paula castillo's
work
and now science update the covet studies
making the news this week long coveted
risks after vaccination and how stress
impacts mortality
some scientific studies have titles that
are really hard to decipher
but this one is pretty self-explanatory
you know straight away that it's about
long covet and whether it can affect
anyone even someone who's vaccinated
one of the most important takeaways is
that the researchers found that
vaccination does lower your chances of
getting long-covered if you end up
catching the disease despite being
vaccinated a breakthrough infection
it also lowers your risk of dying from
the disease
here's a breakdown of some of their
results
first how probable is it that someone
with a breakthrough infection will end
up later with long-covet symptoms
to answer that question the scientists
compared a group of 33 000 breakthrough
patients with a range of different
control groups in total data from around
13 million patients flowed into the
study so it was quite a large one one of
the authors interpreted the article's
long covet results in a twitter thread
compared to unvaccinated people who got
covet 19 he said vaccinated people with
breakthrough infections were 34 percent
less likely to die and 15 percent less
likely to develop long-covered symptoms
so in summary the study helps clarify an
issue that's long been under debate it
indicates that although vaccination does
indeed lower the risk of developing long
covet it does so less than experts had
hoped
it's not a silver bullet against the
condition
[Music]
stress is bad for you everyone knows
that right the authors of this new study
however are a lot more specific they say
they've shown it's bad for the immune
system and can cause diseases like covet
19 to be more severe and potentially
deadly
the researchers looked at the
distribution of immune system cells
called leukocytes and how they change in
situations of acute stress and how that
process is tailored and guided by
distinct regions in the brain
also known as white blood cells
leukocytes help defend the body against
pathogens like saskov2
by the way the study has so far been
published under what's known as
accelerated article preview so it hasn't
yet completed the full editing process
and another caveat the study was also in
mice
that's important to know because it
means we can't be certain the same
things happen in the same ways in humans
even so though the results are
interesting
they reveal that levels of certain white
blood cells fell when the animals were
exposed to acute stress
exactly the cells that are able to
recognize and neutralize specific
pathogens
then the researchers exposed the mice to
the saskov2 virus
and they observed that compared to the
relaxed peers in a control group the
stressed out animals had higher viral
loads and died at higher rates from the
disease
in other words in mice at least stress
seems to play a role in both covet 19
severity and progression
despite progress made in the field of
covid research the virus has resulted in
large numbers of deaths worldwide
so far the virus has claimed over 6
million lives
in london
those who have lost friends and
relatives have organized a memorial site
a place to commemorate those who lost
their fight against the virus
[Music]
one quiet act of love
a collective cry of grief and anger
each heart marking a life in the uk lost
to covet 19
inscribed by friends and loved ones left
behind
the first heart i painted was this one
here
which has got steve's naming so steve
was my partner for a long time and my
husband for three weeks
fran hall is among a group of bereaved
volunteers who helped create and
preserve london's covered memorial wall
it's now grown to over 150 000 hearts
spanning a staggering 500 meters
it's just flabbergasting seeing this
wall now and how far it goes it just
puts it into perspective it allows me to
remember my partner
and and make sure that it's almost
remembered
we'll never forget these people and
obviously no one has
so i really appreciate seeing this
but behind this official looking
memorial lies a remarkable story it's a
renegade project created without
permission
and on the day the first hearts were
painted fran was risking not only a fine
but jail i've never broken the lawn
knowingly in my life so you know there
was a feeling of like oh my goodness i
hope i don't get arrested but actually
at the same time those feeling i
actually don't care i don't care the
worst thing in the world has happened to
me
and i don't care i don't care about
anything like that anymore behind the
scenes they were being advised by the
anti-government activist group known as
led by donkeys who helped set them up
with signs and sandwich boards to appear
as official as possible
over a year later the wall still stands
but it's not without its controversy
deliberately set opposite parliament
it's making a political statement
seeking to criticize the government's
handling of the pandemic
but should a memorial which aims to
represent all promote the political
opinions of some
i think the beauty of the wall is that
it can be whatever you want it to be if
you just want the wall as a place of
remembrance then that is what the wall
can be used for
if actually you feel angry at the
government putting a heart on the wall
is a is an act of almost an act of
protest but it doesn't have to be all
those things the government says it's
planning to establish an official
commemoration
but to creators like tom the grassroots
origins of this memorial are at the
heart of its power we felt really
strongly it was right that this act of
memorialization was was not in the hands
of the government this wall is a is a
people's wall it's a wall for the people
who lost loved ones that i think is the
beauty of it it's been installed by
thousands of people over many weeks and
it's still living and breathing now if
you like
for fran every heart she paints is an
act of love
for her husband steve and the many
others who were lost
it's a wall of
absolute trauma and grief and loss and
fury and rage and confusion
how has this happened in our country
that this many people
have gone they're all dead
they're all dead
and
and this this symbolizes that loss in
such a powerful way
in the years to come it may be hard to
memorialize the loss and the pain
wrought by covid
countless commemorations in countless
countries for countless dead will seek
to try and this wall made by those who
can tell the story of the pandemic best
could be a model as we all attempt to
process our collective grief
that's it for today next week we head to
portugal where the new omicron
subvariant ba-5 saw covet infections
soar despite the warm summer
temperatures
scientists are still researching the
variant which also pushed up portugal's
overall death rate we'll see you next
week
until then stay healthy
[Music]
you